- My next guest is an
inventor and entrepreneur.
In fact, she's recently
turned her passion for ponies
into a whole business
venture. Please welcome.
Ten-year-old Mia on her
invention, the power pony.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Oh my gosh.
I want to hug you so badly,
and I can't cause COVID sucks,
first of all,
I need two of those.
My children are going to
freak out how you just turned
around on that horse. Okay.
A unicorn, I see the horn.
Well, meet Chrissy and joy.
This is Mia.
- Hi, Mia.
- Hi, this is amazing.
- [Mia] Thank you.
- Zipped right out.
- [Joy] That's right.
(indistinct)
- Wait, I was at your kid's party,
- They hopped the ponies
without the power.
- Oh my gosh.
- So they just push down.
- You're kids will freak out at that
that is next birthday party material.
Okay. So what you really must love ponies.
- Yes, so when I turned about two,
I was all over ponies and I was
just watching shows that had
them and.
- Like my daughter, she
loves spirits, just like.
- Yeah, I watch spirit too.
And then when I turned five,
I got him , and I also got a hover board.
So I would put him over the
hover board and it would just
move. So.
- Smart, were your parents terrified
that you were going to break something?
- Yes.
- Okay. I was like, that's
where my brain went,
cause I'm a mom.
So how did you come up?
That's how you came up
with it is you just wanted.
- Yeah, but also when I turned five,
I went, um, to my dad's office
and I looked outside the window
and there was a birthday party
and there was a pony ride.
So I begged my dad to take me,
to take me to like an equestrian
center, just to like ride.
- Yeah
- So a week later I went
and now I'm just obsessed with them
and I can't get off.
- Oh my God. The pink involved is hell.
You're adorable.
Okay.
So, well let's give,
let's give the power pony
a closer look ladies.
I'm not kidding.
I'm going to need to buy two.
- What's the weight on this thing.
- Can I place an order with you Mia?
(girls laughing)
(indistinct)
- (indistinct) 200 pounds.
- Is it?
Oh great.
- Well I've made the cut.
I've made the cut.
- Dress is going to get caught.
This is going to be real bad.
- Zips up my dress.
- You want me to hold your dress.
- Okay.
Wait, I want to see, I want to see,
- Should I try it?
- I think you should,
Mia, I think she's going to give it a try.
She's going to be good.
Let's wait a minute.
Wait a minute. Okay.
Okay. How do you do it?
- There you go.
(audience applauding)
(Chrissy laughing)
- Just put weight, to
go forward and backward.
- Can you bring it back? I don't.
I'm not getting on that. Sorry.
- Chrissy that was really good.
- Look at you maneuvering.
My kids are going to freak. Please two.
I'll put whatever you want.
- Have you done the hover board?
- I've never done a hover board.
Cause I'm afraid I'm going to
die, but this has four legs,
so I'm good.
- [Mia] Yeah.
- So how many have you sold?
- Over a thousand.
(audience clapping)
- Do you know how small you are?
So sold over a thousand
of anything? Oh my God.
- I am so beyond happy.
- Oh my gosh.
I love you. Oh, wait.
So well, joy is a true business whiz.
Okay. So she wants to
share something with me.
Well go ahead.
- Well, first of all, I'm so proud of you.
- Thank you.
- You are so bright and to
follow through with this,
I mean, this is amazing, right?
So, I want to invite you to
come to our set live and see
America's big deal and
meet the entrepreneurs,
and see how they function
and how they create product,
And I would like to mentor you.
I think I'm going to
learn from Mia as when
(indistinct)
(audience clapping).
- Thank-you.
- We can talk or Zoom once a month.
You're from long island, right?
Well, that's where I am.
Isn't that amazing?
- Yes.
- Aww.
- Thank you so much.
- We are so Proud of you.
This is very, this is unbelievable.
You have a very bright future.
- Thank you so much.
- And I'm not just doing
this cause you're adorable.
My kids are going to,
if my kids were here,
they would be so mad at me.
I'm not bringing this home right now.
How does this sound to go there,
and meet other entrepreneurs like you?
- That sounds amazing.
- Oh my gosh girl.
- We can have a lot of fun.
- Yes.
- I am so excited to own two of these.
Oh my God. It's crazy.
- It is.